Bradley Cooper and arena shake  reportedly welcomed their first child  together  [Music]  looks like the 42 year old actor and the  31 year old Victoria's Secret model are  first-time parents according to people a  source confirmed the couple welcomed  their new bundle of joy two weeks ago I  was very exciting ET confirmed the pair  of two years were expecting their first  child in November after the Russian  supermodel debuted her growing belly on  the runway at the Victoria's Secret  Fashion Show in Paris no word on the sex  of the baby ET has reached out to both  Cooper and sheiks preps for comment it's  a big surprise for everyone  congratulations to the new parents  [Music]  you